at what point did you realize that the
character that you were playing is
basically Larry I wish I could tell an
episode and I wish I could remember what
the hell episode it was because people
have asked me for years and I still
can't put my finger on it but it was
early on it was it was in that 13
pickup and my role model on the
character had been Woody Allen when I
first the first bit of scripting I ever
saw for the audition was just six pages
of a scene I didn't have Larry or Jerry
or anybody to tell me what the hell this
thing was and even what context the
scene was in the rest of the script so
excuse me I read it and um I went well
feels like a Woody Allen script so I
went fine I'll do that I'll do Woody
Allen so I went out and got glasses and
I you know forget New York forget what
eventually became New York I was I was
doing the finest Woody Allen impression
you were talking that I could that this
is how I did the audition Jerry
with the sputtering and the spitting and
the whole thing and I and I and when I
did it I went yeah that that's the end
of that I'll never thank you thanks
thanks for calling me in but that was
the only thing I could think of and a
week later I got a call from Larry who
I'd never met and said we love it we
love everything come out you'll read for
the network do the New York just not
quite Woody voice you know and so I
backed off the Woody voice but he was
still in my head the the Cinematic
essential character of Wood Allen that
we've come to know is what I was
thinking
George but somewhere in those first 13
episodes there was an episode where when
we read at the
table it struck me that the basic
situation George was in was absolutely
absurd that it just was a writer's bit
of folly and
Imagination so I went to Larry after the
table read and I said Larry help
me we both know this would not happen in
real life but even if it did no one
would react like this so you're going
for something what are you going for so
that I can figure out how to get there
for you and he went I don't know what
you're talking about this happened to me
and this is exactly what I did I think I
read that story I told you that I heard
you'd say I think it was was it when you
got fired or something no that was much
later on I at that point I knew that lar
because what happened shortly after that
when I when I made that Discovery and I
went oh my gosh I wonder if George is
actually sort of an avatar of Larry and
I started doing something first I
started really observing
Larry and Larry has a physical thing
that he does that I used as my Lynch pin
of understanding George and it seems
like a small thing but if you've watched
Larry perform you've absolutely seen it
so whenever he experiences or hears
something that he's not sure how to
react to like was this a dig what is the
intent of the person saying this to me
Larry does a thing where he takes his
tongue puts it at the bottom of his
bottom teeth and he does this face he
goes
and in curb it leads to pretty pretty
pretty good right you know but it's that
sort of well you you did something there
didn't you you you did something there
and he's thinking about how he's going
to respond to it and I went that's
George that's George George is an
oblivious to how everyone thinks of him
he's well in on it and sometimes he
thinks that too because Larry's thing
for me is always the Larry I knew at any
given moment could say I am the most
worthless pathetic no talent in the
world and why is no one not giving me my
do I should be doing much better than
I'm it was all in the same breath and I
thought that's that's George that was a
standup you I was a huge fan of Larry
when he was doing standup yeah did you
ever see him do his one night and it was
it was a crazy night and um I've come to
know his his act a little bit enough to
know he did his first three standard
jokes but by the end of the third joke
when the the audience did not react he
called us a dirty word and he walked off
the stage always he was always angry and
that for me was my favorite part of his
of his act but also Kirby Your
Enthusiasm you know came out of his HBO
special but coming up with his act right
exactly so he the the beauty of that
show I felt is as crazy as it got it is
always steeped in reality M and you know
even if it's just a um um an
exaggeration of something that really
happened right were there any um uh
Jason Alexander real life things that
end up sein yes no no no in fact
um I'm I'm going to quickly run my own
Rolodex I don't think so
um not that that would never happen I
mean Festivus came one of our writers
right that was foed on him in fact
really no really we did a whole episode
about it and see I don't sure these were
all things that were that came from real
but most of the storylines um at least
in the first four seasons I think four
maybe five Larry Larry was with us for
the first seven and then he was gone for
two and came back for the finale but
many many many of the storylines came
out of Larry's notebooks if you know
Larry well enough he he has spiral
notebooks and he writes down anything
from an odd sounding name that he goes
that's a great name I'm going to use
that somewhere to things that happened
to him or observations or thoughts and
um many times he would say you want to
know when I thought of this look this is
a notebook from such and such year and
here here it is right here the my
masturbation contest you know and you go
oh my God
so he wasn't looking to
me
I